so now we have this graph of this uh
well what's clearly a trig function and
our task is to figure out what the
function is
so let's look at this uh the first thing
i i do when i when i look at something
like this i want to figure out it's it's
period and its amplitude so what's its
amplitude that's always an easy one so
the amplitude
let's write the amplitude amplitude
the amplitude well that's just how much
does it move up and down above and below
the x-axis well the amplitude
here
is how it moves up x-axis well it moves
up one-half above and below the x-axis
so the amplitude is one-half and keep
keep in mind the amplitude is not this
whole distance
it's not this
it's just how much it moves up below
above
or below
the x-axis so in this case the amplitude
is one-half and then we have to figure
out what the period is
the period is how long does it take uh
how many radians does it go through for
it to go through one complete cycle well
if we start here and we were to follow
the graph
it doesn't take until right here until
we complete one cycle right because here
we're still going down and i would go
below so we're not repeating it and
here's where we start repeating again
and then we start repeating again here
so every pi radians we start the cycle
over again it happens the same if you go
backwards into the negative radians
so the period is pi right
period is pi and you could start from
any point you could start from this
point
and if you go follow the graph and then
come back to the same point again
we see once again that the period
is pi radians
now we have to figure out if this is a
sine or a cosine function and for now
we're not will not think about uh
shifting
so let's think about what happens when
you know we want to know what this
function is f of x is equal to
question mark
well we see that f of 0 is 0
f of 0
is equal to zero
what does that tell us is this a sine or
a cosine function
well what's cosine of zero
well cosine of zero is is one
and what sine of zero well sine of zero
is zero and this function is 0.
so we know that this is a sine function
so we know the formula is going to take
the form f of x
is going to equal the amplitude times
sine
of two pi
over the period x
and if we just substitute these numbers
we just figured out we know that f of x
is equal to one half
sine
of 2 pi
over pi
x
the pi's cancel out
and we get
f of x
is equal to
one
half
sine
of two x
now just out of curiosity what would
have what would let's let's define
another function let's define g of x
is equal to
one-half
cosine of 2x
what would this look like
or what would have yeah
the grammar's a little difficult
so let me
i i picked the wrong color because f of
x is actually the pink one this is the
one we have now the g so actually let me
circle that this is f of x f of x is
this one right here
and now g of x
i'm gonna do
so
when x is zero
what is what is well what is g of zero
let's put zero in here what and so this
whole term will become zero what's
cosine of zero it's one
and 1 times 1 half so g of 0 is one half
so we would start here
and then we would have just like the
sine function we would have a period of
pi
because it has the same coefficient here
so this will just look like this
i think you get the point
it's just like the sine function but
it's just shifted to the left a bit
well i'm getting confused on this ignore
this but if you look at this side the
important thing to realize is it
intersects the um the y-axis
at
not one but half and the reason why it
doesn't intersect it at one even though
that cosine of zero is one is because we
have this one-half coefficient right
here i guess you can't call that a
coefficient i guess it's the one-half
times the cosine function
hopefully that gives you a little bit
more of a sense of you know if you just
looked at a graph being able to figure
out uh its equation and i'll actually do
one more video where we'll actually use
the khan academy uh trig graphing module
uh to figure out a couple more
see you soon